Motion graphic videos like these have
been going viral on social media for
years, but they were always so hard to
create or expensive. Well, today I'm
changing everything. You can now create
the highest level that all these big
creators do in a matter of minutes using
AI. I've even used this method before on
my personal brand and gained over 100k
views on a single post. Let's jump into
the complete tutorial. My name is Alex.
Okay, so before I jump into the tutorial
and show you three different ways or
different styles of motion graphics
using AI in a matter of minutes, we're
going to do a few things. Now, the first
thing is I want to show you this account
right here. Now, some of you might be
thinking, you know, motion graphics,
they don't work anymore. Well, you're
wrong. Motion graphics work for faceless
pages, for personal brands, and for
businesses. Here we have Legacy
Academy.io and essentially they've built
their page using these motion graphics.
And you can see that they're
consistently getting 3.3, well, not
consistently, but getting around, let's
say, 50K average. You can see 100, 300,
1 million, 70, 100, 3.3, you know, 30,
18. like on average you would say
they're getting 50,000 views. Now, one
of the great things about this
particular page is they have a very
consistent kind of branding, but they
are a business. So, if I press this link
right here, you'll see that it takes me
to the app store. Okay? And you can see
157 ratings, 40.7
uh, you know, 100 uh 4.7 stars. And you
can see, you know, it's it's a business.
It's working. So them creating these
motion graphics is bringing them more
and more leads. You know, join thousands
building better habits and their content
is clean. You know, it's got this kind
of avatar that they use time and time
again. You know, people replying, it's a
good business model, you know, but
whether you're a business or you're
faceless or you're a personal brand, you
know, I've used this on my personal
brand before. This particular video
right here, this motion graphic got 100k
views again.
big creators like Dan Co who has
millions of subscribers on YouTube and
Twitter etc. He built his brand using
these motion graphics 580,000
likes and we'll actually analyze this
particular real so that you can
understand the different kind of
concepts that make reals uh perform
well. Now, the first thing we're going
to do now is
we're going to start this tutorial and
let's say you wanted to start creating
your motion graphics. You have some
ideas. We're going to go through which
niches this could work for, although I
actually think this probably work for
any niche. But let's go to Pinterest.
So, Pinterest is a gold mine for
inspiration. So, later on in the video
when we're creating stuff, sometimes we
need references. we need um inspiration.
Pinterest is going to be that for you.
And for this, so for example, I've typed
in motion graphics. And you can see if
you type something in, it will give you
like other kind of words associated with
it, you know, and you can see the
different styles that exist here. So you
can see, you know, this is kind of that
Danco style right there. But there's
loads of different kind of ways to use
this. So, and you just kind of scroll
down, but you could type in like, you
know, for example, motivation
and it will come up with more
motivational kind of focused ones. So,
you can see right here, you know, this
one looks pretty epic. Let them judge
you, you know, clean, really good, you
know, here's more, you know, and then
again, you could just type in keywords.
You can type in things like kinetic
typography, logo animation, different
things that could kind of fit what
you're looking for. But motion graphics
are a key style to understand. Now, what
niches could this work for? Now, put
your sunglasses on cuz this part is
bright. Um, so you could use this easily
in the finance and wealth niche. So you
can see spiritual manifestation,
stoicism and philosophy,
educational explainers, tech AI, also
marketing. There's plenty of marketing
pages that do this, relationships,
health and wellness, real estate,
e-commerce, brand content, personal
brands, 100% you can use this for
faceless accounts, you can use it for,
and businesses. Now, the next thing
we're going to do is we're going to go
to this Danco video right here. Now,
when you're analyzing anything, what you
want to do, especially for motion
graphics, is break it down into five
different things. Okay, so the first
thing is timing. How long do elements
stay on the screen? So, you can see
right here, you know, if I was to really
study this, you can use something like
Gemini as well for this. Maybe this
video right here could help you. Um, but
essentially every 3 seconds or so
there's something changing or happening.
Okay, so timing. That's important when
analyzing anything. The next thing is
simplicity. These motion graphics allow
you to give a clear message to your
audience in a very simple way without,
you know, now with AI in minutes. So the
next one is text. And you can see Dan Co
has this very simple text that fits you
know this black and white theme. He also
adds this text sometimes underneath and
that is just a very smart pattern
interrupt. You know people are looking
here middle then suddenly down here then
going back to the top like it's just
classic you know very good content
creation. And then you have audio sync.
If you play this with audio, you will be
able to hear how this all syncs
together, including his voice,
background music, and kind of these
elements, you know, these sound effects,
sound effects. So, really good with that
as well. Now, the final thing is pacing.
So, essentially with pacing, it's all
about how you're delivering the
information. So, he's telling a story.
It's very kind of calm here. you know,
I've kind of gone for a shorter one, but
essentially there's no fancy
transitions, and that's super important
when you're analyzing anything. So, if
you're able to understand those five
things, you'll be able to analyze
anything which you can then apply to
your content, which is going to help you
go viral and understand viral content.
Okay, so now is the moment you've been
waiting for, which is we're going to
create them. Now, we're going to start
off with my one, which is this right
here. And essentially, you know, this
one cost me $100 and took like 3 days to
make. And yeah, um we're going to do
three different styles. So, I'm going to
start off with this one, then we're
going to do one of the legacy ones, and
then we'll do a Danco one so that you
have a kind of full understanding of the
differences. Obviously, we're going to
kind of recreate, but you know, we're
doing that to learn. We're taking proven
content and recreating that so that we
understand, you know, why it did well
and how to create that. And then, you
know, as you start creating your
content, then you start getting more
unique. You start adding your own ideas
and it works like that. Um, so let's
start with this. So, the first thing I
want you to do is basically head over to
Chad GBT. So, something like this. And I
will have all of this in the
description, but you want to put this
image right here, which I'll share with
you, and then this right here. And
essentially what this will do is we want
to have specific kind of instructions
for CHBT when providing us our prompts
for these motion graphics for Nano
Banana, etc. So, I'm going to press that
right there. The next thing is literally
screenshotting two frames of the video.
So, you can see right here, I've got two
different frames. So, let's say like um
that frame right there. I'm going to
grab that. Whilst this is analyzing, I'm
going to go back and get the final
frame. So, I've got the two frames right
there. I'm going to press paste again.
This will be available. You can see here
kind of what it's um done. Okay. And
now, while we wait for that to happen,
we're going to head over to Higsfield.
Now, Hicksfield is an amazing AI
platform that can do everything we need
today. Okay, so you can see here we have
all these new tools constantly updated,
which is amazing. And you can do a small
scroll and see what it's all about. But
we're going to head over to the top left
and we're going to go to image as you
can see right here. Okay. And we're
going to go create image mode.
And you'll see that this kind of layout
will appear. You want to make sure here
you can see all the different tools they
have, but we're going to use Nano Banana
Pro today. And we're going to make sure
that we have 9x6.
So 9x6 is basically this kind of long
format. And you want to, you know, this
is about quality here. I'm going to put
4K. Let's do 4K. Um,
and here you basically choose how many
you want to be created. So let's do
four. Let's just go for max right now.
Go back to chat GBT. And you can see
right here. Boom. So, I'm going to grab
this prompt right here.
I'm going to grab these. So, I'm just
going to literally copy that as well.
Paste that. And then we'll just
literally wait and see what happens.
Now, what we should do is basically
every time I've just done a quick
experiment, but essentially you want to
do is always add a reference. So, I'm
going to actually add this right here.
You can just drag that in, but add your
reference. So, this is my final one, and
you we can see the difference. So, I'm
going to press that again. Remove that.
Go back to my chat GBT and get the first
prompt right there. So, grab that. Copy
that. Boom. I'm back in here. paste
that. Go back to the Instagram. Make
sure that I get the first frame again.
So, let's say I grab that. So, I'm going
to copy that. Boom. And I'm going to
head over to Hicksfield. Put that in
there and see what happens. So, we'll
see if there's a big difference with
kind of um
you know, adding the reference images or
not. Um, but the next thing you want to
do while you wait for this is another
chat right here. And now it's about us
actually animating this. Okay. So, I'm
going to grab this prompt right here.
And again, this will be available. I'm
going to paste that in. So, it's a
pretty hefty prompt, which is why I'm
not going to uh read it word for word.
And I'm going to go back to Hickfield
and see what's popping. So, okay. Sweet.
So you can see kind of what's already
been created. Um.
Wow. Okay. Nice.
And you know without the reference it
didn't do bad actually.
Well it did almost I like it's actually
done really well to be fair. And that is
just proof of how important adding like
the JSON you know prepping your chat GBT
prepping the right prompts. When you do
that properly you know you can
>> [snorts]
>> Yeah. I mean, yeah, you know, look at
the results. So, I should go back to my
CHBT. You can see that this is getting
ready for VO. Now, what you want to do
basically is when you go to Hicksfield
right here is you want to pick your two
images. So, this could be literally
anything. So, for example, let's pick
which one should we pick? Which one
would you pick right now? I'm going to
pick
let's say this one. And the final image
I want um
let's do
let's do this one.
So I've grabbed these two images. I'm
going to go over to Hicksfield right
here. I'm going to drag them in. So you
can see I've got my two images. And then
essentially I will put this prompt right
here. Okay. And I will then press that.
I'm going to go back to my um
Hicksfield. going to go back to the
explore page or kind of the main page
and you guessed it, we're going to go to
video and I'm going to go over to Google
Vo 3.1
and essentially again we're going to add
the two images. So I'm going to just
drag that in.
So this one should be here. Once this
prompt is done, grab it and put it in
here. Now, in terms of quality, I'll put
1080p again, 9 by6. We can choose any of
these seconds. So, let's say I'm going
to go for 8 seconds. And I'm going to go
back to Chat GBT. And quick trick here
is actually you can swap these because
this one actually should be first. Um,
so,
and you can see I just paste that in. So
I'm going to press generate now and
you're good to go. So now we just wait.
So I will see you in a moment. Okay. So
Hicksfield is done or VO3.1. Let's have
a look.
Yo, that is crazy. So it even added
sound which works really well and it
basically did the whole thing perfectly.
Now, the only thing I was concerned
about, which basically was that the this
guy has hair and this guy doesn't. So,
it's kind of just, you know, blended
that in. But if you were to do this
properly and, you know, post it, you
would obviously make sure that your
first guy has hair and the second one
has hair and or, you know, vice versa.
But you can see in a matter of my
literal first video, this is my history.
It's worked perfectly. The next thing
we're going to do is upscale this to 4K.
So, you're going to download the video
when you're happy with it. And
essentially what you do is once you've
downloaded it, go to video upscale. So,
grab that right there. And you want to
just literally slap that video right in.
Um, and from there you can see the
different options. You know, for this
one, I'm going to use Topaz. I'm going
to press 4K advanced settings. I'm going
to use the thea one and press upscale.
And then the final thing is going to be
literally editing this in capa. And it's
going to be as easy as one, two, three.
So I will see you there right now. But
trust me, upscaling makes a massive,
massive difference. And you'll see that
in a moment. So let's open Cap Cut and
upload our upscaled video and zoom it in
by 2%. We'll mute my sound completely
and use a viral sound just like I did in
my 100,000 views one. And we're almost
done at this point with one thing
remaining, the text. For the text, we
need two of them. The first one is for
the full sentences, and it needs to be
elegant and thin. Cap offers a lot of
fonts, so pick one that resembles this,
and you're good to go. The second font
is all about keywords, and here's where
the boldness comes into play. Again,
there's literally tens of these fonts. I
just went with the classic font, turned
on my favorite color, purple, and here
we have it. A simple animation is
needed. And again, you can find a lot of
them in the text effects and it's good
to go. Here's the recreation of my
100,000 views motion graphic.
So, as I promised you at the beginning
of the video, by the end you will know
how to create content like this page and
the other two as well. Now, you will
have everything you need to create this
style of content in my description. So,
be sure to check that out. And while
you're there, press the like button cuz
it gives me feedback and really helps.
You know, a lot of effort go into these
videos. Um, now using the same tactics,
you'll be able to create this, okay? And
it will look something like this.
[music]
>> Because this one is similar to the
previous one, we're going to now head
over and spend a bit more time on the
Dan Co style as that one is more
storytelling, has more elements. So,
let's head over there and really take
this all to another level.
Okay. Okay, so next up we have this very
specific style which Danco and there are
others are very well known for. Now this
is a very simple black and white you
know simple text not much effects not
much music just raw sound effects with
the voice over. Now for this one we're
going to use our good friend Gemini 3
from Google which is on steroids right
now and it's very very capable in this
kind of content marketing world. Now,
Gemini 3 is a bit pricey and sometimes a
little harder to work with than Chat
GBT, and that's why we use CHABT at the
beginning, but it has a lot of good
options. And one specific one that I
like is the way it's able to analyze
video content. And again, if you want a
full video about Gemini and the way
different usages in kind of this world,
this video right here is amazing for
you. Now the first thing you want to do
is basically [snorts] uh download this
video. So download this video you know
grab the video done you know you can use
a website like this or however you
download videos and essentially we go
over to Gemini. So here on Gemini and
I've put the video in and you want to
put a simple prompt. So we're not going
to do some massive JSON prompt right
now. We're going to do a simple prompt
like this and we're going to press
submit and see you know what we get from
it.
Okay. So, it's given us a kind of real
indepth um you know understanding or
analysis of this video which again is
I'm not going to jump into today but you
can learn a lot with this. Um and I'm
going to now paste this prompt. Okay.
So, I don't want it to generate images
but I want it to actually start telling
me you know each image I need to create
on Higsfield or my AI. So, I'm going to
paste that right now, and you will see
everything I get from that. So, whilst
we wait for that, I'm going to head back
over to Higsfield. I'm going to go to
image, [snorts] and you hit right here.
I'm going to find Nab Banana Pro again,
my good friend. I'm going to just reset
all of this.
Again, we can do the same thing. 9 by6,
4K.
You can do smaller batches, unlimited.
It's all up to you. and we'll go back to
Gemini and see what's done. Okay, so
perfect. So now essentially I will do
prompt by prompt each one. So I will
grab this and I will copy that and I
will paste that right there.
And I'm just going to generate and see
what it kind of comes up with. Okay, so
you can see that these images have come
out pretty clean on Nano Banana. And
again, what you want to do is literally
kind of just pick the ones you like. And
we're about to animate this. So, you
know, I'd pick like this one and just
kind of download it. And then go one by
one. Then we'll head over to Gemini. So,
I'm going to head over to Gemini. And
you would put this prompt. So, you put
your images and then I would put this
prompt right here. So, again, this will
be available in the description. And you
can see I get all my animation prompts.
So, I'm just going to grab this one.
Perfect. I'm going to press copy. I'm
going to go to Nana Banana. I'm going to
go to VO. Now, again, Higsfield has
Cling. It has literally everything. WAN.
So, you could use any of them. It's
worth testing different ones depending
on, you know, what you're trying to
create. But again, we're just going to
go with Google. And for this, it's as
simple as this. So, I'm going to grab my
exclamation mark and put it in there.
And I'm going to 6 seconds is good.
Really, these should only be about 3
seconds, but having slightly longer
load. So, the 6 seconds is going to
allow us to actually have a little bit
more kind of room in terms of the
editing. So, I'm going to basically
press generate on that. Okay. So, we've
got our video and you can see right now
it's animated it. So obviously if I
wanted it to be animated in a different
style etc I would do that. But for our
first one it's done an amazing job. Now
what you would do next is obviously
animate each one and then we'll head
over to our editing software and put
this all together and create our magic
which I'm about to show you. Okay. So
we're back on Cap Cut and let's upload
all our segments and zoom them again by
2%. The next step is to mute all the
content sounds and add auto captions.
This should be kept as easy as possible.
Half of the sentence should appear on
top and half of the sentence on the
bottom. Make sure to cut all the
segments properly so they are in sync
with the voice over. And the last thing
is to add sound effects that match the
animations. As easy as that, guys. And
now let's take a look at how the black
and white motion graphics look like. Be
careful telling people your goals. It
releases dopamine, similar to actually
achieving them. Don't get trapped in the
mental masturbation cycle of planning to
change your life but never actually
doing it. Life is a game and eventually
you're going to have to face that
monster and then the next until you have
a story worth telling people about. Now,
we were able to do all of this today
using Hicksfield, which is one of my
favorite AI content creation platforms,
and I've been using it for a while now.
It has a super clean interface and it
allows beginners to seamlessly jump in
and create entire workflows from
character consistency to product
placement to motion graphics in a matter
of minutes. If you want to try it, be
sure to use the link in my description
and you can get an extra 10% off. If
this video has helped you in any way, be
sure to drop a like so that I know I
need to create more like this. Now, be
sure to check out these playlists right
here, which are going to help you if you
want to dominate social media, AI, and
content creation this year. You don't
need to make life harder. You need to
make life smarter and easier. My name is
Alex, and I'm here to make you grow this
year. Let's jump into My name is Alex.
Be sure to subscribe and like. I will
see you on the next